- [Instructor] The goal of
this video is to appreciate how
ideas of natural rights and
social contract and limited
government and popular
sovereignty are embedded in
America's founding documents.
Before we start looking at the
documents themselves, let's
just make sure we understand the context
in which they were written.
As we enter into the mid
1770s,
you have the beginning of
the American Revolutionary
War, which begins in 1775.
A little more than a year
after the beginning of the war,
you have the Second Continental
Congress decide to formally
declare independence on July 2nd
and the Declaration of Independence,
which we will study a bit in this video is
formally approved on July 4th,
1776,
which is when we now
celebrate Independence Day,
even though some could argue
that it was July 2nd.
Now, as soon as the colonies
decide that they are
independent from the Kingdom
of Great Britain, they have to
think about how do we govern ourselves?
Within roughly a week, a little
more than a week after the
Declaration of Independence
is approved, they start
drafting the Articles of Confederation.
Remember the Revolutionary
War is still going on.
Eventually what will be
known as the Articles of
Confederation go into effect in 1781.
Now, this Articles of
Confederation really treat the
various colonies as you could
almost view it as separate
states that agree to work
together for purposes of getting
independence from Great
Britain, for purposes of
fighting the war, for
purposes of diplomacy.
Now, over the course of the
next several years, it becomes
clear, especially through
things like Shays' Rebellion,
which we will look at in other
videos that the Articles of
Confederation don't provide
a strong enough central government.
In May 1787, you have what
is called as a Constitutional
Convention convening.
It's presided over by George
Washington, who led the
Americans in the Revolutionary
War, which they eventually
will win as you see and obviously
we're independent country now.
The original intent of the
Constitutional Convention was to
revise the Articles of
Confederation, but folks like
Madison and Hamilton were
really intent on just completely
replacing it.
What they replace it with
was what is now the US
Constitution, which goes
into effect in March of 1789
and shortly thereafter,
you have the beginning
of Washington's two terms.
To be clear, the idea of even
having a powerful executive,
the idea of even having a
president was not present in the
Articles of Confederation that
comes with the Constitution.
With that context out of the
way, let's look at, especially
the Declaration of Independence
and the US Constitution.
Here's the beginning of the
Declaration of Independence,
written by Jefferson and edited by
Benjamin Franklin and John Adams.
I encourage you to pause this
video and first try to read
it on your own and see if you
can identify these ideas of
natural rights, limited
government, popular sovereignty,
republicanism and social contract.
Let's read this together now.
When in the course of human
events, it becomes necessary
for one people to dissolve the
political bonds, which have
connected them with another ...
Remember, this is a
Declaration of Independence.
They are dissolving the political
bonds with the Kingdom of
Great Britain and to assume
among the powers of the earth,
the separate and equal station
to which the laws of nature
and of nature's God entitle
them, so that's starting to
refer a little bit to natural
rights, a decent respect to
the opinions of mankind requires
that they should declare
the causes which impel
them to the separation.
They're saying, "Hey, we're
writing this document because
"we're trying to show the rest
of mankind why the reasons
"for which we are deciding to declare
"our independence from Great Britain."
We hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal,
let me underline this, that all men are
created equal, that they are
endowed by their creator with
certain unalienable rights,
that among these are life,
liberty and the pursuit of happiness.
This is a direct reference
to natural rights.
In fact, the phrase life,
liberty and the pursuit of
happiness, most historians
believe is in direct reference
to John Locke's phrase
life, liberty and property
when he talks about natural rights.
This is direct reference to
the enlightenment ideas or even
the pre-enlightenment
ideas of natural rights.
That to secure these rights,
governments are instituted
among men, deriving their
just powers from the consent
of the governed.
This is worth underlining as
well because they're talking
about governments being
instituted among men to secure
these rights.
This is all about social
contract, so that's social
contract that we form a government
in order to secure rights.
We might give it some
rights, but in exchange the
government has to protect our rights.
They derive their powers from
the consent of the governed.
Let me underline that actually
in a different color, derive
their powers from the
consent of the governed.
That is popular sovereignty,
popular.
I'll just write as pop sov,
popular sovereignty right over here.
That the people are the sovereigns.
That whenever any form of
government becomes destructive to
these ends, it is the right
of the people to alter or to
abolish it and to institute
a new government, laying its
foundation on such principles
and organizing its powers in
such form as to them shall
seem most likely to effect
their safety and happiness.
This is more about social contract.
They're like, "Look, if a
government breaks its social
"contract, we have a right to replace it."
The document also makes reference
to organizing its powers
in such form, so that's really talking
about limited government.
They're talking about, "Hey,
this government just won't
"have the absolute right to do anything,"
so that right over there is limited
government.
Prudence, indeed, will
dictate that governments long
established should not be changed for
light and transient causes.
They're essentially saying,
"Look, you shouldn't just
"overthrow your government on
a whim," and accordingly all
experience hath shown that
mankind are more disposed to
suffer while evils are sufferable,
than to right themselves
by abolishing the forms to
which they are accustomed.
They're saying, "Look, if you're
prudent, you wouldn't just
"overthrow your government on
a whim," but they're kind of
saying, "We're not so worried
about that because history
"has shown us, experience has
shown us that if anything,
"people are more likely to
keep suffering even when they
"should be overthrowing their government."
But when a long train of abuses
and usurpations, pursuing
invariably the same object
evinces a design to reduce them
under absolute despotism,
it is their right,
it is their duty to
throw off such government
and to provide new guards
for their future security.
They're saying, "Hey, look,
the Kingdom of Great Britain,
"they are abusing us,
they are usurping power."
Usurping is taking something
from you that is yours and so
we need to throw off such a government
for our own future security.
Here it says,
"Provide new guards for
their future security,"
so this provide new
guards, once again making
reference to limited government.
Now, let's fast forward
roughly 13 years to the US
Constitution, which continues
of course to be in effect.
This over here is a picture
of the Constitutional
Convention, which we
mentioned happened in 1787.
The original intent of the
Constitutional Convention was to
revise the Articles of
Confederation, but folks like
Alexander Hamilton and James
Madison really wanted to
replace the Articles of Confederation.
You can see it's being presided
over by George Washington.
It starts, the preamble says,
"We the people of the United
States, in order to form a more
"perfect Union, establish justice,
"insure domestic
tranquility, provide for the
"common defense, promote the
general welfare and secure the
"Blessings of Liberty to
ourselves and our posterity, do
"ordain and establish
this constitution for
"the United States of America."
Once again, pause this video
and think about whether you
see ideas of popular
sovereignty, limited government,
social contract, natural
rights going on even in this
preamble or even from the fact
that they took the trouble
to create this constitution.
Well, let's start at the beginning.
It starts with, "We the people,"
we the people are the ones
that are creating this
Constitution and not only does it
start with we the people,
but we the people is
intentionally written in
this very, very large writing
right over here.
This is a picture of the Constitution.
It's really of all about we
the people, the people are
sovereign, so
this idea of popular sovereignty comes out
loud and clear in not just the
Declaration of Independence,
but also the US Constitution.
The fact that we the people
are setting up this government,
this is all about social contract.
They are forming a government.
They're forming a social contract
with a government that is
going to protect, that is
going to establish justice,
provide for the common defense,
promote the general welfare.
Let me make this clear.
That is this, this is all social contract.
This is what we expect, this
government that we're creating
to do, promote the general
welfare and secure the blessings
of liberty to ourselves and our posterity.
Now, what about things
like limited government?
Well, just the very fact
that we have a constitution
is a sign of limited government
that it isn't just a pure
democracy that whoever is governing
is going to be constrained.
The rights of the government
are going to be described by
this constitution.
We also talk about the
Blessings of Liberty, so this is
another reference to natural rights.
The Declaration of Independence
is a little bit more clear
about natural rights or a little
bit more explicit, but the
Blessings of Liberty does
talk about or that's maybe in
reference to natural rights.
I will leave you there.
As we study US government,
both the Declaration of
Independence and even more
so, the US Constitution are
going to be things that we keep
going back to to understand
how we are trying to form a
more perfect union and what is
in line with the vision of our
Founding Fathers and what isn't.